Selwyn
some of the most exciting moments of
your life have won Academy Awards like
the car chase that made you sit on the
edge of your seat in Bullitt those
fights that made a step in champion
Raging Bull and rocky these all won
Oscars for film editing joining their
ranks right now is one of the following
nominees Christopher Ralph's for the
Bourne Ultimatum Juliet well flame for
the diving bell and the butterfly Jay
Cassidy for into the wild
Roderick James for No Country for Old
Men Dylan Tichenor for there will be
blood and the Oscar goes to
Christopher Rao's for the Bourne
Ultimatum
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Christopher rouse
forty-eight years ago my father was
privileged enough to receive an Oscar
and I'm I'm deeply deeply honored that
you've put me in his company tonight to
the brilliant Paul Greengrass to Frank
Marshall thank you thank you thank you
to everybody in post-production led by
my good friend and colleague mark
Fitzgerald each and every one of you
sharing this award with me to Universal
Pictures to the Academy my deepest
deepest thanks to the amazing Matt Damon
thank you and to my family especially
Anna
I know Ava and Fiona my kids I love you
thank you so so much
no no hello film editing Wow someone
just took the lead in their Oscar pool
based on a guess all right can we give
it up for mr. bill Conti Oscar
award-winning down now how you doing
down there you all right you hold it up
let me get hot down there you guys have
been down there all night it's terrible
you all right yeah there you go when did
you guys switch trombones these guys are
great